already considered one of the strongest
storms Canada has ever experienced Fiona
made landfall in Nova Scotia early
Saturday morning bringing 150 kilometers
per hour winds and heavy rainfall the
Canadian Hurricane Center says the
storm's preliminary barometric pressure
reading was the lowest on record for
Canada the lower the pressure the more
powerful the storm
we're thinking first and foremost of the
people who've had a terrifying past 12
hours people have seen their homes
washed away seen the winds ripped
schools roofs off
but as Canadians as we always do in
times of difficulty we will be there for
each other
about 100
kuwaited in Halifax the previous Capital
nearly three quarters of Nova Scotia was
left without power as Crews raced to
restore electricity and missed
widespread reports of downed trees and
power lines the mayor of Halifax told Al
Jazeera he had no doubt climate change
made the storm worse with climate change
in particular and the volatility of
weather these days we've been getting
more of these hurricanes Fiona's
northward path then took it through the
Newfoundland town of portal Basques a
woman was rescued from the sea after her
house collapsed according to police
widespread damage led the mayor to
declare a state of emergency posting
this video to Facebook actually hi uh
I'm going live here again and going to
be pretty direct now with people we're
in the process here of calling a state
of emergency our town is in all intense
purposes we are already in a state of
emergency
no serious injuries or fatalities were
reported in the hours after Fiona came
ashore the authorities cautioned the
danger is not yet over Fiona has
weakened but may pick up energy again as
it continues to move north
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera